hi this is Karen reporting at Macworld
at Moscone north and we heard a rumor
that Steve Jobs is walking around that's
right folks
Steve Jobs is here somewhere I just seen
at Moscone South reports
thanks Karen it's true there have been
reported Steve Jobs sightings here at
Moscone South that is where I am and
you're gonna find him oh my gosh they're
steamed now let's go in interview hi
Steve Steven Paul jobs hi I'm Justine
great to meet you
can I get a quick interview great so
what can we expect here at Macworld this
year
Stephen can you tell me how does it feel
not to be doing the keynote this year
Stephen how can you how do you feel
about that okay
and now please tell me one more thing
one question I don't know if you've ever
had that's great thank you so much I'll
talk to you soon thanks Karen back to
you thanks just stands for that
exclusive fantastic interview the Steve
Jobs we'll see you at macro for more
news and stuff more news and stuff why
wasn't she wearing pants why didn't you
ask him bat I don't know okay bye
I'm Steve Jobs some people like to call
me Steve Joel Joel was let's know how
you say one new C you're tossing to me
blah blah blah
thanks Karen it's true there has been a
Steve Jobs sighting here at the Moscone
which one is this Musca name Hey hi hi
hi hi what's up what's up macro are you
there are you there well I'm not